la juridiction régionale de libération
conditionnelle réunis à caen dans le
calvados a donné un avis favorable à la
mise en liberté conditionnelle de
patrick henry
celui ci avait été condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité en
1977 pour le meurtre d'un enfant de 7
ans si cet avis est suivi patrick henry
pourraient être libérés dans un délai de
quatre semaines commentaires yasmina
ferveur avec florence bukiya ce jour là
c'est la huitième fois que patrick henry
fait une demande de remise en liberté
mais c'est la première fois qu'elle est
examinée par des juges avant la loi de
janvier 2001 sur la présomption
d'innocence seuls les gardes des sceaux
avait le pouvoir d'accepter ces requêtes
pour les longues peines jacques toubon
et il y avait des digues ou avait refusé
la liberté à patrick henry un condamné à
perpétuité sans doute trop symbolique
la france a peu symbolique parce qu'en
ils enlèvent puis tu es un garçon de 7
ans suspecté par les enquêteurs il
nargue la police et les médias alors que
l'enfant est déjà mort symbolique parce
que robert badinter son avocat sous la
tête de ce jeune homme de 23 ans alors
que l'opinion veut la mort
aujourd'hui la justice a pu examiner le
dossier d'un détenu modèle 100 patients
on sait que le dossier patrick ollier
avait été présenté à deux reprises à
plusieurs mises la justice il était déjà
bon mais
s'agissant d'une responsabilité
politique on a assisté de la part des
ses responsables à une sorte de dérobade
jeu satisfait de voir que les juges se
sont montrés politique
les magistrats qui ont pris cette
décision souligne les modalités de cette
éventuelle mise en liberté
conditionnelle
il sera suivi pendant une période de
cette année il y aura des dons des
contrôles à subir il devra répondre aux
convocations
on contrôlera son travail les mesures
habituelles d'assistance et de contrôle
si le parquet ne fait pas un ultime
appel patrick henry sera libre à 47 ans
il ya 23 ans il avait fait une promesse
aux jurys tués avait permis d'échapper à
la peine de mort
vous ne le regretterez pas